homelessness because of pressures in the
private rental sector has increased in
England over the last three years and as
a whole there's been an 18 rise in the
number of households receiving Council
support because of a no-fault eviction
well our analysis of data from the
government shows a need for that help
has risen most in the Northeast that's
by 88 in fact there's been an increase
in nearly all regions except for the
West Midlands
a correspondent Adele Robinson reports
on the findings
well we're on sat there and
until after before we're officially
almost tomorrow
I've lost words
this is a story about Sally and Ollie a
family falling through the cracks so
it's Sunday morning and
been quite happy yet
and I'm just waiting for my taxi now and
I'll
come back on in a bit when I'm at the
hotel I mean I have never got to stay
because we're classes homeless
like thousands of others forced into
temporary accommodation after being
evicted from their private rental
well I'm now South outside Hotel
Oliver's been really good
I'm making it into a little journey for
him
and his time at heart breaking
through him unto myself
a Sky News investigations found local
authorities are spending more on
temporary accommodation for those made
homeless like Sally every year figures
from almost two-thirds of council show
if Trends continue while over 600
million pounds will be spent in this
financial year more than 100 million
pounds extra nearly a quarter above
pre-covered levels outside of London it
will be a rise in spend of 55 percent
what we're seeing happen all around us
is part of a wider systemic issue
unaffordable housing means more people
are renting privately rents are higher
than ever because of a supply issue
partly and crucially social housing has
been sold off faster than it's been
replaced which means the squeezed
private rental sector has become a
substitute for social housing
I'll do it so if Sally had been in
social housing her local Council would
never have had to spend money on her
temporary accommodation a costly system
described as a national scandal is also
economically illiterate and
dysfunctional that we're throwing ever
increasing the amounts of money to pay
for that rather than dealing with the
problem that sourcing building social
and affordable housing that the country
so desperately needs
the governments say their affordable
homes program will help deliver more
houses and are giving councils more than
300 million pounds to help prevent
homelessness
finally somewhere to stay after weeks in
a hotel and what's it like being here
now
good cause obviously a best met lives up
straight so I get to see him and I get
to play a little bit more now a
resilient Ollie but his mother bears the
emotional scars of homelessness another
victim of the housing shortage that's
costing councils billions
bank I don't want fancy things
just give me a break
Adele Robinson Sky News